covit 19 ans coronavirus les eas aux
maladies du coronavirus il ya près de
deux mois
le monde découvrait cette nouvelle
maladie apparue en chine en quelques
semaines à peine cette infection
respiratoire a touché plus de cent mille
personnes et fait plusieurs milliers de
morts
sa propagation a provoqué des mesures
exceptionnelles des millions de gens ont
été confinés et ressortissants étrangers
rapatriés d'urgence puis mise en
quarantaine d'événements rassembleurs
annulé c'est du jamais vu dans le milieu
scientifique aussi le virus a suscité
une mobilisation sans précédent
les chercheurs du monde entier se sont
attelés à la tâche de comprendre et
contrer le plus vite possible
cette nouvelle menace avec une rapidité
inédite
ils ont échangé ouvertement leurs
analyses et leurs réflexions sur divers
sites internet et dans les médias
sociaux
plusieurs grandes revues scientifiques
ont accéléré la publication des travaux
sur ce nouveau virus en quelques
semaines et dizaines d'articles sur le
sujet avait déjà paré
retour en arrière le 7 janvier
des chercheurs chinois identifié à 1
chez des patients atteints de pneumonie
un coronavirus jusqu'ici inconnu à peine
trois jours plus tard il publier sa
séquence génétique
grâce à cette information de nombreux
laboratoires ont pu rapidement mettre au
point des tests diagnostiques pour
détecter l'infection
depuis des dizaines d'autres
échantillons du virus ont été récoltés
sur des malades et leurs génomes ont été
décryptés en un temps record ces données
ont permis aux experts de les comparer
pour reconstituer en quelque sorte
l'arbre généalogique du pathogène il
montre que le nouveau coronavirus est un
proche cousin du strass un autre
coronavirus qui avaient tué près de 800
personnes en 2003 mais ses plus proches
parents se trouvent chez les
chauves-souris d'une piste pour les
chercheurs qui veulent identifier une
heure où les animaux d'où l'épreuve le
virus le moment de cette transmission de
l'animal à l'humain intéresse aussi ni
scientifique
là aussi la génétique les a aidé les
génomes analysés sont tous très
semblables le virus aurait donc
relativement peu évolué depuis qu'il se
propage dans la population humaine
ces faibles variations suggère qu'il
circule depuis la mi novembre environ
si on considère qu'une premiers patients
recensés est tombé malade début décembre
cela signifie que cette nouvelle maladie
a été détectée rapidement et pas assez
pour empêcher sa propagation
deux aspects du virus sont
particulièrement cruciaux sa
contagiosité
combien de personnes un malade infecté
et sa létalité combien risque d'en
mourir
les chiffres sont encore incertains mais
en moyenne un patient atteint du corps
d'un virus pourrait affecter un peu plus
de deux personnes
son taux de mortalité lui se situerait
entre 1 et 3%
comparons le à d'autres virus
respiratoires
d'abord son cousin le virus du strass il
est à peu près aussi contagieux mais
plus virulents il a tué un malade sur
dix avant d'être enrayée en 2003 la
rougeole elle est beaucoup plus
contagieuse mais tue moins de 1% des
gens qu'elle infecte la grippe aviaire
peu contagieuse très mortels quant à la
grippe saisonnière
il était un peu moins contagieuse que du
nouveau pour un virus et eu un malade
sur mille environ
c'est relativement peu mais il faut se
rappeler que le virus de l'influenza
affecte chaque année des millions de
personnes au canada il en tue trois
mille cinq cent par année
si le coronavirus suscite tant
d'inquiétude c'est surtout à cause de sa
nouveauté
a priori personne n'est immunisé contre
lui il pourrait donc faire beaucoup de
victimes
de plus il n'existe pour le moment ni
traitement ni vaccin pour le contrer les
scientifiques qui travaillent mais cela
prendra des mois
d'ici là notre seule arme c'est de
circonscrire d'épidémies et de traiter
au mieux les manades on le fera d'autant
mieux que progressera notre connaissance
de l'inpi
dans notre monde
hyper connectés et virus voyage de plus
en plus vite
heureusement la science accélère aussi